I am pleased to welcome to the platform
William J Clinton President of the
United States dr. David dijo graduate of
the Harvard MIT division of Health
Science and Technology professor at
Rockefeller University scientific
director and chief executive officer of
the Aaron diamond aids Research Center
in 1996 Time magazine man of the year
and the Honorable Francis J do hey Mary
mayor of the city of Cambridge dr. ho
will now give his address
thank you it's great to be back good
morning
President Clinton mayor do hey president
best mr. Dubois members of the MIT
corporation and faculty to the graduates
and their families and friends my
heartfelt congratulations it is indeed a
momentous day in your lives what an
incredible honor it is for me to return
to MIT as a commencement speaker as a
young immigrant boy growing up in
Southern California I was awed by this
August institution from afar my love for
science was inspired by the genius of
extraordinary man like Feynman Luria
Baltimore and ting whose presence at one
time on another graced this campus later
it was within the Harvard MIT Health
Sciences and Technology program where my
clinical skills were home where my
scientific interests were solidified and
where I truly learned to tackle research
with a multidisciplinary approach not
limited by arbitrary boundaries that
separate biomedical sciences from
physics chemistry engineering and
mathematics I will forever be indebted
to you I'm here today because I've been
given a great deal of praise and
recognition for recent advances May in
AIDS research achievements in research
seldom belong to a single individual
science is a richly collaborative
endeavor and my personal recognition is
merely symbolic for the many important
discoveries and contributions made by a
cadre of talented scientists in the
field as Newton aptly put it in a letter
to Robert Hooke if I had seen further it
is by standing upon the shoulder of
giants
the recent media attention focused on
age research has provided a unique
opportunity to educate the public a
large abala plague of staggering
dimensions and to advocate to our leader
a proper course of action it is also
gratifying to see that the media is
willing on occasions to prominently
feature scientists book accomplishments
that move our society forward however on
a personal note I find that spotlight is
hot enough to bake and as scientists as
Einstein had caution the only way to
avoid the corruption of praise is to
keep on working I feel extremely
privileged to work on AIDS as a young
physician in Los Angeles in 1981 I was
fortunate enough to witness the
beginning of the visible part of the
epidemic over the course of a year young
men one after another presented to the
hospital with the multitude of
infections leading to death within days
to weeks it was evident that their
immune system was damaged but by what
their medical history strongly suggested
possibility of a sexually transmitted
that caused immunodeficiency and yet any
description of a similar syndrome was
nowhere to be found in the medical
literature the disease was obviously new
in this manner aids appear insidiously
and mystified doctors and scientists
alike no one could have predicted that
17 years later we will face a global
epidemic of HIV infection that is
arguably the plague of the millennium
today HIV continues to spread an
alarming rate of 16,000 new cases
des and more than 50 million infections
are expected by the year 2004 a
biomedical scientists what could
represent of greater opportunity than to
conduct research on a lethal microbe
that threatens the health of the entire
world members of the class of 98 as you
move on in life be prepared to take
advantage of the opportunities that have
bubbled up by serendipity then have the
courage and conviction in pursuing your
goals and ideals in science and
engineering you have chosen noble
professions once filled with excitement
nothing is more thrilling to me than the
process of scientific discovery when the
wonder of nature is revealed one is less
breathless and awestruck imagine the joy
and intellectual satisfaction when the
constant expansion of our vast universe
was discovered when the complex nature
of the chemical bond was understood or
when the double helical structure of DNA
was solved imagine the excitement that
must have pervaded this campus when the
synthesis of DNA was achieved from an
RNA template imagine as well the fruits
of science the sense of accomplishment
in those engineers when an electrical
current was transformed into light when
sound waves were transmitted across long
distances in a while or when a cushion
of air was harvested to send men soaring
into the sky allow me the more modest
but personal anecdote beginning in 91 my
colleagues and I had the privilege of
working with structural biologists and
medicinal chemists
to test small chemicals that my
intercalate into the catalytic site of
the HIV protease and enzyme essential
for the production of infectious progeny
virus so overwhelming was the excitement
that overtook us when substances were
found to potently inhibit this enzyme
thereby blocking viral replication in
the test tube three years later we again
had the privilege of being the first to
administer one of these chemicals to
infected patients unmatch where the joy
and amazement as we watch the level of
HIV fall ever so dramatically at first
little did we know that we were sitting
on top of a fundamental discovery in
AIDS research but shortly thereafter by
simply asking why does the virus fall
and why does it fall in that manner it
quickly donnas that HIV must be turning
over rapidly in a very dynamic
equilibrium with a host using data from
patients working with mathematicians we
proved HIV replication in the patient
was rapid and remorseless in the course
of only a few weeks the old paradigm
that HIV was largely a latent virus was
completely shattered so incredible was
the ensuing intellectual satisfaction
that I now fully appreciate the meaning
of the line in a book the ascendant man
it reads when the answers so simple then
you hear God thinking despite the
breakneck speed of scientific discovery
in the field AIDS patients already faced
a decade and a half of horror and
disappointment but because of science
there is hope in the past two years with
new knowledge and new
therapy it has become possible to
control HIV so effectively that the
virus is no longer detectable in the
infected person this dramatic attack is
associated with the substantial clinical
benefit to the patient for the first
time in this dreadful epidemic the tie
has began to turn against the virus
although a cure is still not in hand as
stated in Time magazine the worst fear
the one that seeded a decade with the
spear the foreboding sense that the AIDS
virus might be invincible has finally
been subdued after years of cursing the
darkness of AIDS a candle of hope has
been lit by science aids however is not
over worldwide most infected persons
cannot access the promising therapies
and much remains to be done in
controlling the spread of this epidemic
it is my deepest hope and that the
recent scientific advances will inspire
government academia and the private
sector to remain vigilant and to
redouble our efforts to bring an end to
this tragedy prevention is the ultimate
key to controlling the epidemic and
vaccine science must now take center
stage as was declared by President
Clinton last year recently my thoughts
have taken me on a number of
self-reflective journeys
let me humbly share a few were the
graduates in our experiments attempting
to eliminate HIV from an infected person
I've learned that success in research as
is the case in most endeavors requires
both decision making and a willingness
to take inform risks as so eloquently
stated by Harris Shapiro of Princeton an
excessive zeal to avoid all risk is in
in an acceptance of mediocrity and an
application of leadership graduates you
must take on the toughest challenge but
view it as the greatest opportunity for
every noble work is at first seemingly
impossible heed the wise words of Teddy
Roosevelt before the turn of the century
far better it is to dare mighty things
to win glorious triumphs even though
checkered by failure then to rank with
those poor spirits who neither and join
or suffer much because they live in the
grey Twilight that knows neither victory
nor defeat more and more I've also
reflected on the role of science in our
society I'm disturbed by the public's
indifference to what we do as scientists
and engineers as children we all began
with a real desk for science we we were
curious and provocative and insightful
questions blurted out constantly
however by early adulthood this
proclivity to science when the joy of
discovery have somehow dissipated in
most only to be replaced by science
phobia consequently it is not surprising
that our society has often stereotyped
unflatteringly
those scientists and engineers who carry
out incomprehensible lines of work
Edison Bell and the Wright brothers
would be today's nerds even though the
products of their ingenuity have made
our world better I'm particularly
saddened by the fact that many of my
personal heroes and science are virtual
unknowns to a typical citizen while
certain dubious characters by
universally recognized and often
glorified by our society a scientist and
engineer we must change this by learning
to present our work in both interesting
and understandable ways indeed it is our
responsibility to bring back that spark
the sense of wonder about nature that
lies within every citizen I'm equally
troubled by this society's lack of
commitment to research in basic science
the former president said in a campaign
speech why should we subsidize
intellectual curiosity this simple but
naive question speaks volumes of the
lack of the appreciation of the richness
that uninhibited fundamental research
has brought us Carl Sagan said it best
when he wrote Maxwell wasn't thinking a
radio radar and television when he first
scratched out the fundamental equations
of electromagnetism Newton wasn't
dreaming of space flights or
communication satellites when he first
understood the motion of the moon Rankin
was in contemplating medical diagnosis
when he investigated a penetrating
radiation so mysterious
he called it x-rays Curie wasn't
thinking of cancer therapy when she
painstakingly extracted my new amounts
radium from tons of pitch boy Fleming
wasn't planning on saving lives of
millions with antibiotics when he
noticed circle free of bacteria around a
growth of mold Watson and Crick weren't
imagining the cure of genetic diseases
when they puzzle over the x-ray
diffraction pattern of DNA these
discoveries and multitude of others that
grazed and characterized our time were
made
ultimately by scientists given the
opportunity to explore what in their
opinions were basic questions in nature
cutting off fundamental curiosity-driven
science is like eating the seed corn
George Washington said in 1790 there is
nothing which can better deserve our
patronage than the promotion of science
knowledge is in every country the surest
basis of public happiness graduates in
the best tradition of MIT always
maintain unwaveringly a deep commitment
to excellence as you enter a career in
science or engineering stay in the
forefront of your chosen field and never
permit the excellence of your work to be
compromised
believe in what you're doing as Max
Planck said over the entrance of the
gates to the temple of science written
the words he must have faith it is a
quality which the scientists cannot
dispense with I remember where the great
deal of fondness might mate from the
class of 74 just like you what a bunch
they are they were stay young at heart
but should you need to grow do not
suppress your individuality and insist
on conformity continue to let
imagination and creativity percolate
throughout your lives for every great
events in science has issued from a new
audacity of the imagination
said John Dewey I'll also reflect it on
the contribution of my heritage to my
career we're not for the profound Asian
respect for intellectual achievements
and scholarly endeavors a scientist I
might not be today more ever values of
drive dedication imprinted during early
childhood have continued to serve me
well in any culture
there's simply no substitute for hard
work
I've been an American for so long that I
often forget that I'm also an immigrant
from time to time I could still sense
the desire that burns in the belly of a
new immigrant the desire to carve out a
place in the new world in the land of
opportunities to this day I maintain an
underdog mentality that motivates me to
a higher level of work ethics let me
begin to close with a comment throughout
its history
America's continued to benefit from the
drive labor and creativity of immigrants
many in the field of science and
engineering
just look among the graduates this
morning thus today one prevailing view
that immigrants constitute a constant
drain on society is simply baseless
wrong and shameful particularly in this
nation of immigrants
graduates as future scientists and
engineers it is likely that you will on
occasions be underappreciated
under-recognized and more likely
underpaid by our society you'll have to
take solace and satisfaction in knowing
that your work has helped to build a
better safer healthier and richer world
a world with hope members of the class
of 98 it matters not whether you work on
numbers atoms molecules machines
organisms the earth or the cosmos
through science and technology any one
of you can cast a giant shadow on our
planet congratulations and don't forget
to thank your parents
you